a couple of notes firstly this is really
under the heading of logs lot is where
we're really going to dig into it but as
you know equations with emphasis in
equations with mods are the same
equations just written differently
different point of view secondly I'm
really focused on the inequality part of
this right you guys have been working
with the equations a fair bit today and
master your the end of last year but
when you move into inequality is even
though like it seems like a fairly
trivial difference between solving an
equation and solving it's sort of
equivalent inequality equivalent
inequality
whatever when you when you're working
with if this is lawns and transferring
between them you've got to be very
careful so let's start like this we'll
start with a simple thing that we know
it like say for instance if I said X
trivially trivially simple example like
this okay now I know what that you know
what the answer is that you can just
read it off but I want to start with a
simple enough example so you don't get
weeded out by the notes if I were to
convert this into a log equation instead
of an additional equation how would I
write it I'm gonna start with X
long love beasts bass [ __ ] all day it's
good okay since I'm growing at rate -
how long will it take me to get to eight
and the answers three so so far so good
when you've got any quality right it's
very easy to convert into a log equation
by the way I started with X equals but
you could just as easily have said this
now the reason why I point this out is
because even though you know because
it's an equation you can put it on left
insight you put on right side doesn't
matter but if I were to change this into
an inequality right
you can't play so fast and loose anymore
because the left and right are not the
same anymore so you can't just simply
say I just put one wherever and then
just going for it okay now again because
this is a simple example I think you can
see what the answer to this is going to
be like you can read off the number
without doing it with logs okay but if
we are going to do with logs which side
assuming the young inequality stays in
the same direction which side does the X
belong on okay so if I if I take these
two parts you write the X is going to
stay on the same side okay now just
watch for that third that's not like
some golden rule that's always true it's
true because in this case what I want is
this now let's illustrate this okay so
it's worth picking up another color to
draw yourself a said ask you what does 2
to the X look like it can actually need
a bit more space see soon the X is just
your standard exponential curve and it's
doubling and www.and it's doing
something like that okay now when I put
this first line I'm saying if this is to
the X I'm looking at where it's higher
than 8 higher than it okay so that's why
their owner
somewhere I'll pick you up okay so where
is this graph higher than eight and the
answer is well if I bring this across
there's the point where it intersects
really should be a hollow circle
shouldn't pull this circle dad okay and
I'm interested in the part that's a buck
that's at this part here okay so the
corresponding X values that mark the
solution to do this are going to be X is
greater than three right that makes
sense so that's fairly intuitive this
positive direction maps to this positive
direction so far so good is that right
okay sir so far things stay put but
let's try another example okay if I said
this this yeah
great of them yeah well let's just make
let's put a boundary just for the sake
of it okay we use equations as our our
lens to understand equalities because an
equation write an equation it will be
the boundary point for the corresponding
inequality does that make sense like if
you just take it take away all the
inequalities just change it to equals
when you solve that you'll find the
boundary where you turn one way or the
other okay so when you have a look at
this 1/2 X if we wanted to find the
boundary you'd say that equals 2 all
right now you can tell me what the
answer is but how would you work it
how would you demonstrate how you get
the answer okay all right I could go
straight to logs but there's a simpler
way isn't that before we get there even
though that's fine
okay sir if I can avoid logs like if I
can keep things in the language they
already are then I'll do that if it
wasn't like if they weren't nicely
numbers like if it was something like a
half the pair of X equals seven then
I've got no choice Lourdes is where I
have to go because it's not going to be
nice in there right but this time I can
I'm just going to compare coefficients
right and the solution to this is one
good okay now this is a bit harder
because you're familiar with like how
normal expenditures work but this got me
if you were to graph this what does it
look like
okay there's two different ways of
speaking about it number one again think
about that growth rate idea right if
this is your growth rate what's
happening to your object slash
population slash whatever is changing
it's it's decrease is having every time
period right another way I've seen that
is it's this right so this guy flipped
horizontally that's that's what happens
when you put a minus sign of the X okay
so now what does this look like you
really need to draw this it's going in
the opposite direction it is as we would
say in the edge of c-course
exponentially decay you okay as it gets
smaller it keeps getting smaller but
it's rip up getting smaller gets smaller
it slows down okay so this is what it
looks like where is this solution this
solution is perfect here there's x
equals minus 1 and as we expected the
reason why it's over there is because it
maps up to here there's two so there's a
solution now let's get returned back to
the original question we wanted when is
this graph when is it above or equal to
two where is that
if this pot up here isn't it this is the
part of the graph I'm interested in here
are the corresponding y-values and so
you can see now the corresponding X
values aren't going not to the right but
to the left okay so if I had done the
same trick just thinking like blindly
algebraically oh when you take logs of
books when you convert it into a log
equation right you just leave the X on
the same side where you would write this
you go X is greater than or equal to log
base 1/2 of 2 right but that's wrong
that's not sure I want X is greater than
X is less than because he okay is he
divided by a negative right okay so
because when you transition for me to
here it's not obvious because we're so
used to thinking in terms that all you
just change it it doesn't matter which
sides which okay when you did this we
actually we skipped a step okay now to
try and make this most obvious to you
there's a few different ways we could do
this okay
here's the way I'm going to suggest make
it really really obvious when I look at
this okay
I'm going to forget that I know that
it's minus one okay I look at this and I
can see I'm one I want to go to the left
right because I want to go upwards so
what is this value in log terms
hmm well my base is going to be like
whatever this growth rate is which is a
half right yep so it's gonna be log base
F off and I want it to be like I'm
growing to such a rate that I'm too
now you notice that's backwards in time
all right because this thing is
shrinking right okay so now I know that
the real solutions of this actually is
coming you know X is less than or equal
to whatever this value is okay now all
this time I've been using easy numbers
so you can just see it but if I give you
disastrous messy numbers that don't give
you nice integer
Solutions okay you will be reversed to
resort to actually solving it
algebraically so how do you work with
the arithmetic here how are you gonna
work out what this and this is what
rules do we know that can help us work
with this if some different choices okay
I could convert the base I could commit
the mate but if I can just work with it
in its present base I bet might be
giving me a bit an easy solution right
can anyone see how I can work with this
thing while leaving the base is 1/2 what
am I got over here yeah Darce okay now
if I'm putting a minus 1 pair right you
can't just throw it right this one's
around
I mean you've got a this is now this is
the same right now I haven't changed
this all right so this is really log
base 1/2 of that just 1/2 and the whole
thing is ^ -1 but I know I know
I can just put that there right see that
my power has come out to the coefficient
log base 1/2 or behalf that's negative 1
okay so be very very careful when you're
doing these inequalities okay your best
strategy is just drew a picture and then
you learn conclusively which direction
you have to go in and what your
inequality will end up with all right
until you get more used to it